I see that this is the approximate use of 1.82 million years, so it
would be nice if there was a way to cut it down to 1.82 million years, but it would
be like that if it became a home video.
But of course a man would have done that many times, right? I'm
interested in this situation where we're alone in a room together in Mizuhara.What's
this fish talking about?I feel like I'm being watched naked.I'm
curious about Mizuwon's movements.
The distance is closer when I'm on the plan setting screen, but since it's a
private space, I'm
always conscious of the unusual smell of the laundry and the lipstick on my
lips.I'm a serious
weapon that stimulates me.  It's
not a meeting, it's not a date, I'm
listening.Here's the photo you asked for, but I just sent it.
[Music]Cute
That's about all we have to say about the budget.However, there are a
lot of things that aren't finalized, and I
don't need a character like Mizuhara.
It's a movie for me. I
said no. Suwon, where I'm raising money, should not
appear. I only offered Suwon as an actress. Let's
do our best, or I'll do it.